[Musik]
ja ich mache jetzt mal besser nicht
weiter gebaut und jetzt willkommen beim
ein video jahr wollte was geht ich hoffe
euch geht's gut auf jeden fall kam
genau heute vor einer woche das video
instagram bilder mit 0 likes dass auf
jeden fall haben wir euch angekommen hat
mich gefreut und was ich gerade gesehen
habe das muss ich einfach mal kurz an
sprechen da war ja so ein kleiner junge
dabei der hat halt ein foto hochgeladen
hatte irgendwie nur likes und darunter
geschrieben fußball ist geil habe ich
gesagt er geht doch mal drauf und zeigt
dass alle und ich kam dort echt nicht
klar ihr habt da wirklich nicht 1000
sechs tage lassen auch nicht 2000 auch
nicht 3000 sondern fast 4000 xalter was
geht also da muss ich auf jeden fall mal
sagen ihr seid krass ich habe mir auch
so gedacht vielleicht kommt er ja ein
kleines dankeschön von dem jungen an
mich zurück aber irgendwie juckt sind so
gar nicht und ihr habt es wahrscheinlich
schon unten ist ja der titel hat das
wahrscheinlich schon gelesen es geht
heute um youtube-videos mit nur likes
meine mitbewohner die schnell an der
stelle ist ihm scheißegal hat mir ein
paar rausgesucht so ein paar videos der
wirklichkeit haben und die schauen wir
uns jetzt zusammen ich bin gespannt was
da auf mich zukommt kurz erweckt auch
mein mertes online wenn es noch nicht
mitbekommen habt ganz oben der videos
verlinkt so was gibt's da zum beispiel
diesen rudi denn jetzt natürlich auch
noch ruhiger als in pink mit seiner
weißen aufschrift feiere ich mega dann
gibt es auch noch andere motive wie zum
beispiel diese frisur hier von mir und
alex wieder darunter das gibt es
natürlich auch auf police und hoodies
und t shirts und was richtig und ketchup
so cap
das hier ist zum beispiel wie kerber
schon wieder zu viel werbung also wenn
ihr mich unterstützt und mich cool
findet oder so dann könnt ihr euch gern
was bestellen okay und jetzt fangen wir
an
ich bin mehr gespannt wenn ich so die
titel lese green leaf in japan block 9
cents monkey sind fix it webcam girl
sexy striptease die gavotte okay also
wirklich alles videos mit 0 likes wir
schauen uns erst mal den nonsens
markieren
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich hat mit der jetzt die
ganze zeit vor dem spiegel und machte
super an sich ich weiß dass mir ja es
gibt ja echt dieses video wo so mehrere
tiere von spiegel gestellt werden und
kein einziges tier checkt dass das ein
spiegel seit ihr dunkler gut war auf
jeden fall witzig danke für dieses tolle
video so als nächstes kommen aber zum
japan- lockt japan blog wieso war
[Musik]
als der darf einfach in der schule
filmen die stelle mir vor ich komme so
mit meiner fetten ich habe meine kamera
geholt seinem blog handy ist echt geil
komme ich so in die uni sagt so guten
morgen die will mich alle wie so ein
auto angucken weil ich da mit einer
kamera ein laufe dann für den unterricht
dann mal die mitschülerinnen war wie
können wir gar nicht klar
ich muss jetzt gerade mal sagen da ist
deutschland wirklich echt sein abgefuckt
das land weil die sind einfach so alle
so wirklich alle lehrer würden das
niemals erlauben allein schon wenn ich
in der schule waren foto machen wenn man
handy von der tafel so weil ich mit
schreiben wollte kam eigentlich immer so
die antwort eigentlich davon dass wir
nicht aus datenschutzgründen der film
einfach in japan den ganzen unterricht
der film seine mitschüler der familien
und kein jux in deutschland wer sowas
niemals möglich sei jetzt muss ich mal
kurz aufregend finde ich auf jeden fall
mega schade dass es kein leck hat weil
an sich der blog geht jetzt noch fünf
minuten länger das tun wir uns nicht an
jetzt ist die frage schauen wir uns
jetzt schon das webcam sexy girls
triptis an oder erst am schluss wir
machen mal kurz die queen die fische
spinnen
das ist ein song okay jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
[Musik]
älter geht ja voll ab wieso hat sowas
bitte nur likes ist voll geil die habe
niebels die kassen und widgets bin also
wenn ich meiner betrachte juni ich frag
mich gerade wie hat er das gefunden wie
kommt man auf so was das musste erst mal
finden auf youtube ich meine da gibts
bestimmt über 10 milliarden videos nicht
mehr
ok dann schauen wir uns jetzt mal das
schwein an alter war das total
verschieden hund meint das tut ihm
schwein ja aber es scheint wenn es
wehtut
lasst nicht so mit junghänel kratzmann
das sitzt einfach da wie ein hund die
behandeln das so als wäre das so deren
haus die so also ich würde es einfach
mal schätzen das sind engländer
vielleicht haben die in england ja keine
hunde als haustiere sondern schweine
da muss man auf jeden fall mal klatschen
ist ein richtig geiles video a
das hat jetzt auf jeden fall meine
denkweise im leben um einiges verändert
dankeschön dass ich mir das anschauen
durfte so leute und jetzt kommen wir zu
dem moment auf den wir wahrscheinlich
alle gewartet habt jetzt kommt nämlich
der webcam girl sexy striptease ich bin
jetzt echt gespannt was da passiert weil
nachher wird mein video gesperrt was
hast du da rausgesucht
[Musik]
ganz jetzt mal irgendwas machen ja ich
mache jetzt mal besser nicht weiter wir
wollen ja nicht dass mein video gesperrt
wird aber mal kurz die frage an dich wie
solid für sowas von auf youtube hoch an
die ganzen kleinen jungs jetzt wollte
wahrscheinlich wissen wie das heißt
webcam girls sexy striptease dance den
kanal namen verrate ich nicht da müsst
ihr selber drauf kommen ja heute so viel
dass man dazu das waren jetzt fünf
videos mit 0 1 ich verstehe nicht warum
das video nun likes hatte ganz ehrlich
das macht für mich keinen sinn nur noch
ein partner ist auf jeden fall noch nach
oben da ich würd sagen bei 12.000 likes
ist das easy drin und checkt meinen
workshop ist ganz wichtig auf jeden fall
chaplins ab wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder oder vielleicht wenn ihr in der
umgebung von nrw wohnt in soest bin ich
morgen um 19 uhr im red bull
direkt am bahnhof kommt darum wenn der
bock habt ja das war
haut rein